vulcania s'éveille aujourd'hui le parc
d'attraction des volcans voulu et lancé
en 1992 par l'ancien président de la
république monsieur giscard d'estaing et
donc inaugurait aujourd'hui lowen s'est
ainsi doté d'une attraction touristique
contesté par certains écologistes en son
temps mais qui finalement voit le jour
au pays des volcans en andorre sophie
rodier à la location saint-ours les
roches cette petite commune tranquille
et surtout connu pour ses vols quand ils
sont éteints depuis des millénaires
et pourtant ici c'est l'effervescence on
inaugure vulcania une tour haute de 28
mètres trône en plein coeur des volcans
d'auvergne 57 hectares consacrés au
volcanisme mare de boue lave
incandescente
nous sommes en plein coeur d'une
éruption volcanique
on a même un geyser ci qui comme ses
homologues le naturel fonctionne de
façon intermittente les cinq dix minutes
il excuse un jet d'eau chaude et de
vapeur à 2,3 mètres d'altitude
on n'est évidemment pas dans les
habitudes atteinte par les geysers
naturel qui peut faire 50 60 m
cinq ans de travaux pas tout à fait
terminé des équipements ultra
sophistiqué mais le parc a été conçu
pour un large public
on n'est pas là pour remplir la tête des
gens de quantité de choses très
scientifique mais s'est un peu arrêté
par le très austère comme veut être la
science est tellement on est là pour
leur faire découvrir un des phénomènes
les plus grandioses de la vie de la
planète et le volcanisme et tous ses à
côtés un grand rêve pour son initiateur
valéry giscard d'estaing qui a souvent
tourné au cauchemar
il a notamment dû composer avec les
écologistes locaux
résultat la facture est élevée 100
millions d'euros au lieu des 35 millions
annoncés et maintenant aller